it looks way better so what the heck
sony whoa okay so that's a discovery
all the cameras suck literally they all
suck well not all of them there's two
cameras that definitely don't suck i can
show you right now this one doesn't suck
if i'm trying to make a video i'll bring
the red obviously it's a super high-end
camera it's also really good for
high-end photos too it's a little big
though this thing also it doesn't suck
it does everything the red doesn't do
it's small it's waterproof you can put
it anywhere so on one side we have ultra
high quality video and also great photos
if i need them and then on the other we
have lightweight versatile weatherproof
goes with you everywhere and for years
i've been trying to find something that
kind of combines these both and that
hasn't existed until now
it didn't take much to guess that it was
an a7iii i'm super super excited about
this camera just came in and i'm dying
to use it well why look at this this
thing is tiny it's super tiny but what's
really important about it is what's
inside this camera has a sensor that is
basically the same size as the one on
the red and it's gonna give me that nice
cinematic look suddenly why do i need
this camera i got this red i got this
gopro well i just had a baby boy and he
needs some portraits also i'm trying to
practice my cinematography more often so
a camera that's full frame with a nice
lens on it is going to replicate using
the red pretty well so it's going to get
me experienced in my career and also
fulfill a ton of stuff that's happening
in my personal life it's a great in
between for that so b h has sent this
camera over to us on loan and i'm going
to test it out and see if it's something
i want to keep so we got to test this
baby out and i think there's a few
scenarios that will really show us what
it's got first off i want to go out with
nick and clint and do some cool
nighttime photography we're just gonna
be on foot so the lightweight package
hopefully is going to help you're
looking spooky yeah this is this is cool
just gonna pre-take some gels onto these
little m9s here you never know when you
want a little color it only looks good
in the close-up first shot of the night
smoke bomb photography so clint is going
to volunteer here you have a 50 and i
have a 28. let's uh let's see how this
goes
dude that looks so cool clint you look
like a wizard in the mist do you see
this
no it's just great it's like everything
is a set now
this is a holga medium format film
camera and this is a nikon 35 millimeter
film camera
black and white a7 r2 with a 2470. like
juggling cameras man don't drop them
[Music]
the second test i want to do is a video
test i want to show you guys how the a7
3 reacts in super low light conditions i
want to compare it to other sony cameras
to see if it's worth upgrading i also
want to compare it to our red to see if
if we're on a big shoot do we want to
whip this guy out i also want to compare
to the canon cameras because that's the
next closest competitor to this dude the
baby life dude i go to bed at 8 30 all
right
and i wake up every two hours
until i get to work
[Music]
what's going on man
thinking man
about what
well mostly about squarespace because
this episode is brought to you by
squarespace but more importantly when i
come up here to think about life's most
important questions like is life more
than what we think it to be i ask the
eight ball
you may rely on it life is more than
what we think it to be squarespace is
also more than you think it to be you
don't need to take it from me does
squarespace have beautiful award-winning
designer templates
signs point to yes does squarespace have
award-winning 24 7 customer service it
is decidedly so does squarespace have an
all-in-one platform so there's nothing
to install patch or upgrade ever it is
certain is squarespace flexible for any
kind of website most likely if you sign
up today by going to squarespace.com sam
and nico will you get 10 off your first
purchase most likely as in yes will sam
and nico let me combine the channels
no
we got some footage ahead of us here
let's take a look and see what is the
best we're trying to go in with a micro
minimal lighting setup to really test
the low light capabilities on a
technical level on a consistent level
let's compare the we're gonna call them
the three and the two for now for a
seven three a seven s two three and the
two all right so i think we're getting
some color shifts between these two guys
here makes sense in motion there is
certainly noise so you can see that the
the three definitely has sharper if you
look at the bricks okay so the sharpness
on the three definitely better than the
sharpness on the two like we use the
exact same lens on both cameras so the
three is definitely sharper okay good
and as far as noise is concerned pretty
similar amount of noise between the two
images you can see the wood grain much
more clearly than you can up here
let's take a quick look still between
this and the canon all right well there
we go the canon canon's imaging quality
like we're at the exact same settings
the same shutter speed the same aperture
there's just nothing the sensor is not
making anything with the light that it's
being given like there's just no
comparison right now last comparison is
the red okay so here we go now we
actually have a legit comparison here
obviously there's a small color
difference but when it comes to a
clarity and crispiness standpoint at 4k
here they look really similar but i
think the proof here is that i can take
my red footage still
and blow that up quite a bit more 100
for the red footage and 100 for the a7
so now 200 boom all right here here we
go now we're seeing the difference the
red is clearly a better camera we
already knew that but this is proof when
it comes to just sheer image quality now
let's make things more difficult let's
go up in iso and really see how this
footage starts falling apart 3200 iso
a7 iii a3 looks good compared to the
a7s2 all right boom once again we have
our sharpness difference drops off
considerably a7s2 is not holding up
there you see that like even in the hair
right there everywhere everywhere
everywhere so a72 it's just softer it's
softer all across the board the a7 3's
video capabilities are a huge step above
the other sony mirrorless cameras to the
canon god ugh it looks like we're in
high school again making short films
that looks so bad the red
a worthy comparison still still
maintaining a crapload of sharpness as
far as actual visible noise here still
quite comparable the
sharpness of the noise is staying pretty
proportional aka 8k footage has smaller
grain but
there's just as much of it across the
board here hey i'm not going to drop
this looks really cool yeah so basically
the eighth is the a7 three and it's the
red oh right it's holding up really well
the braid is holding up really well all
right so 6400 iso look how nice this
looks wow there is certainly noise there
wait did it get wait does this look
better
dude i think the noise reduction is
kicking in by that point yeah look holy
cow look at that it actually looks
better at 6400 than it does at 3 200. so
on the left is 6400 and then on the
right is 3200 whoa okay so that's a
discovery
we are cranking the cameras to much
higher settings on the left than we are
on the right yet it looks way better so
what the heck sony is this so is this
where your noise reduction really starts
this is the high iso noise reduction
that i see in the menu holy crap this is
so cool i'm really digging this so let's
kick it up one more here we are 12 800
iso oh
the cannon dude that's my goth album
cover
dubs and darkness the red is this is
just a mask it's a massacre so now let's
just go to like the crazy the crazy
settings let's go to a hundred thousand
all right now this is where the noise
really starts just it creeps into
everything here like the color i'm sure
it's all fuzzy yeah but once again the
places where there is light there's
light there already you know so it
doesn't get too noisy and then once
again compared to the two in summary the
a7 iii completely kills it when it comes
to low light and it also kills it
completely when it comes to comparing it
to any of the other video capabilities
of sony mirrorless cameras i'm totally
blown away and also the true secret that
came out of this is seeing the point at
which the noise reduction kicks in on
the sony camera i was unaware of that so
this is super cool and actually it gets
me way more excited to use these cameras
again but before i go out again we still
have to look at all the sweet photos we
took it's been a really busy week we've
been finishing up the pub g video but we
finally have a chance now to look at
some of these pictures we took while we
were out there because we want to see if
the photographic quality the a7 iii is
better than all this other junk well we
already know it is because i'm seeing a
lot of noise in here it's kind of like
film grain this is all processed look at
that wizard in the dark right there but
here's here's that image with clint
unprocessed raw this does not look
nearly as noisy this is all raw it's
crazy yeah so this is actually really
smooth there is noise and there is
artifacting and like the processing i
applied to it really brought out the
noise but like when you're looking at
the actual images here let's say you are
shooting super low light like this
definitely don't want to be putting
extreme color grays on it because the
footage is very
very delicate it's fragile
this is 2000 iso because there are
lights in the scene that are
illuminating it and when you take a look
at this image close-up compared to the
other one
oh yeah it is
very sharp it's very crispy still it's
like a bagel that you just put in the
toaster for like a little too long but
too long in a good way you know what i
mean like the crispiness the crispy this
is the edge the crispy
crumbs will drop when you bite into it
you know here's another clean one this
is not a lot of like there's less light
i would say even in the super dark areas
it's there's grain but it's very muted
that's pretty nice and sharp though sam
what was your favorite pick that you
took out of the excursion well i like
these ones because of the sheer like
rigid industrial like crispiness i like
that from a technical perspective just
this test how clean of an image you get
here what are your favorites yeah hold
on you want to do a little intermission
here
always be prepared oh i keep a hal bird
under my pillow
i was shooting in black and white on the
camera it was one of my one of my color
profile settings was just black and
white i did that because noise kind of
turns into green
when you're in black and white so it
kind of like works off of your
limitations yeah because you don't get
like the green and purple noise yeah
it's like it's like
it turns into turns into like a film
grain kind of like so and you can see
it's kind of crusty that's cool so we
got a before and after ooh so this is
kind of gives it a film look for sure
eight mil camera yeah yeah really
that looks clean and crispy here's a
here's a good comparison so like when
taking pictures of people out in the
wild it's kind of awkward so you want to
be quick so i didn't have time to change
my settings so when i took the shot it
was super blown out and you were able to
pull it down to that brought it down to
this yeah you're not shooting her all
right i am oh you are shooting wrong
yeah always there's this guy here which
was that looks cool i took i took that
and like changed yeah that's interesting
i like that
what's your favorite photo this one's
cool and then probably this one that
that's the elevator you have gift shots
whoa so i'm getting like the same thing
in the grain this is edited in photoshop
kind of a good comparison it's kind of
the same dude i love like the random
like cactus stamp
so yeah the brain pops for sure but this
one which i like oh color correction
that's great um and this one came out
really crisp i think this was at 64.
that's really sharp yeah super sharp
what lens was that this was uh i believe
my 28 millimeter broken on prime
is this one i really like this this chef
guy
little little window into the soul of a
chef this guy's just at work man
i don't know that's that he looks behind
a kit like he's behind a cage oh
that's really nice let me see the flaws
right away i can see all over the image
your image is so much sharper than this
one we also had different lenses i was
working with prime lenses and i was
pretty wide open so my my depth of field
and focus is nothing almost the focus
plane's like right around here it's like
a potato chip so what do we learn here i
learned that all these cameras take
amazing photos they all take quite nice
photos using autofocus lenses especially
when it's night time helps not doing
manual primes using skinny lenses
even though these are stills the visual
reference and photo reference still
gives you a really good idea of what the
video will look like since
the images are so similar so the
question is sam are you keeping the
camera
oh yeah i'm keeping the camera i want to
go on again we had a ton of fun going
out and taking photos it's really great
we're going to definitely do it again
but we want to know which photo was your
favorite in the comments below take a
look at the photos and leave a comment
with your favorite one and the winner is
going to get a steven's book leave that
comment leave a comment